with u.s russian relations the most
tense they've been since the end of the
cold war
talks to try and defuse a crisis
america and russia's deputy chief
diplomats their frosty body language not
encouraging and failing to make progress
on the issue of ukraine joining nato
russia's deputy foreign minister has
compared this crisis to the cuban
missile standoff which took the world to
the brink of nuclear war
after the talks he wasn't sounding
compromising
we need
ironclad waterproof bulletproof
legally binding
guarantees not assurances not safeguards
guarantees with all the words shall must
everything that should be put in this
bowl
never ever becoming member of nato
can i put you the words of the ukraine
ambassador this morning on sky news who
said that many dead russian bodies will
be returned to moscow if putin moves
against his country
does that worry you
it is worrying because
it shows how
nonsensical many ukrainian officials are
russia is demanding sweeping security
guarantees that nato will never let
ukraine join as a member and will end
its activities in countries in eastern
europe that have already joined america
says that as a non-starter but is
prepared to talk about military
exercises and missile deployments
leaving a huge gulf between the two
sides
with a hundred thousand russian troops
on ukraine's border there is a lot at
stake miscalculation or clumsy diplomacy
could lead to escalation and conflict
the buildup that russia is undertaking
right now
is
leaving them an option to conduct what
would be the largest
military operation in europe
maybe since the second world war
after eight hours of discussions they're
still far from any agreement except to
carry on talks when nato meets russia on
wednesday the next chance to reduce
tensions and avert conflict dominic
wagon sky news geneva